guten abend und wir kommen zu zdf heute
live es ist ein schritt den man als
historisch bezeichnen kann denn finnland
und wohl demnächst auch schweden wollen
in die nato und das nach jahrzehnten der
neutralität finnlands präsident und auch
die regierungschefin haben sich heute
offiziell für einen beitritt
ausgesprochen
in der erklärung hieß es damit werde die
sicherheit finnlands aber auch die des
bündnisses als ganzes gestärkt es gab
auch schon erste reaktionen aus moskau
darauf die vielen erwartungsgemäß alles
andere als positiv aus darüber wollen
wir sprechen mit christian mölling er
ist experte für sicherheits und
verteidigungspolitik von der deutschen
gesellschaft für auswärtige politik und
davor mit mina hollander
politikwissenschaftlerin von der
stiftung wissenschaft und politik mit
dem schwerpunkt nordeuropa und die
begrüße ich jetzt zuallererst einen
schönen guten abend frau orlando guten
abend sie stammen aus finnland haben
nach wie vor engen kontakt zu land und
leuten wie würden sie derzeit die
atmosphäre dort beschreiben wie groß ist
die angst vor russland ich würde die
stimmung als der entschlossen
beschreiben auch gewissermaßen
erleichtert dass jetzt endlich dann
sozusagen die staatsführung auch ihre
haltung bekannt gegeben hat die eben wie
erwartet sehr positiv und die natur
perspektive unterstützung ausgefallen
ist darauf hat man einfach gewissermaßen
gewartet weil der prozess ist ja schon
sehr weit fortgeschritten
gewissermaßen ging es auch tatsächlich
von der bevölkerung aus also die
stimmung ist zunächst in der bevölkerung
wirklich sehr schlagartig um oder der
umschwung war sehr schlagartig in der
bevölkerung also das ging quasi über
nacht am 24 februar als russland dann
die ukraine angegriffen hat und so wurde
der ganze prozess eigentlich form der
bevölkerung so betrieben beziehungsweise
von der öffentlichen meinung zur hre
vorangetrieben und und die politik
musste er dann da sozusagen die
öffentliche meinung gewissermaßen ein
holen also insofern sind alle einfach
gespannt jetzt darauf wie es weiter geht
ja über diesen meinungsumschwung der
wirklich bemerkenswert ist nach
jahrzehnten über den werden wir dann
gleich auch noch ausführlich sprechen
auch noch mal der hinweis an unser
publikum ihr könnt natürlich auch gerne
wie immer mitmachen fragen und
kommentare entweder in die
kommentarspalten oder an die
eingeblendete adresse an uns per mail
und bevor wir weiter sprechen frau oder
bringt uns meine kollegin heike kurse
noch einmal auf den aktuellen stand der
dinge sie berichtet über die ereignisse
des tages und darüber dass sich dieser
schritt finnlands schon seit längerer
zeit angekündigt hat
eine internationale frühjahrs
militärübung in finnland obwohl das land
noch nicht nato mitglied ist sieht man
seit jahren gemeinsam ins manöver nur
5,5 millionen einwohnern finnland immer
fast 900.000 soldaten und reservisten
gold genau vorgegeben wir haben sogar
all die jahrzehnte ein gewisses niveau
aufrechterhalten während die übrigen
europäischen länder überlegt haben sich
auf krisenbewältigung zu konzentrieren
bei uns dagegen stand immer die
nationale verteidigung im mittelmeer wo
es gemerkt eine nato-mitgliedschaft
finnlands wird tag für tag
wahrscheinlicher präsident minister und
ministerpräsident in marihn erklärten
heute schriftlich
als ein nato-mitglied würde finnland die
verteidigungsgemeinschaft stärken
finnland muss die nato-mitgliedschaft
unverzüglich beantragen wir hoffen dass
die nationalen schritte für die
entscheidung schnell innerhalb der
nächsten tage erfolgen nach umfragen
sind inzwischen drei viertel der finnen
für den nato-beitritt
ich denke es ist richtig das zu tun
angesichts der lage in europa und in der
ukraine
wir sind gut damit gefahren nicht in der
nato zu sein ich finde wir sollten das
nicht tun am montag wird das parlament
debattieren auch dort zeichnet sich eine
mehrheit für den nato-beitritt ab egal
wie regierung und parlament gemeinsam
entscheiden finnland erhöht schon jetzt
den verteidigungshaushalt um zwei
milliarden euro allein in den kommenden
vier jahren
frau holland der präsident und
regierungschef in wollen also eine
schnelle entscheidung sind wir gerade
auch noch mal lesen können was ist ihre
einschätzung wie wird das jetzt genau
ablaufen in finnland ist das jetzt nur
noch eine frage von tagen genau das ist
der fall tatsächlich also erstmal wird
dann eine konkrete empfehlungen der
staatsführung sozusagen an das parlament
gegeben das wird am sonntag erwartet
dann wie bereits erwähnt wird am montag
das parlament debattieren und dann noch
ein beschluss fassen und da sieht es
sehr gut aus eben also derzeit haben
sich 150 von 200 abgeordneten für den
beitritt ausgesprochen
nach einer einschätzung das vielleicht
noch zur ergänzung nicht nur unseres
korrespondenten aus brüssel könnte
finnland wenn alles nach plan läuft noch
in diesem jahr offizielles nato mitglied
werden also nicht nur in finnland hat
man es offensichtlich eilig sondern auch
in brüssel ein sehr straffes verfahren
ist da vorgesehen das ist also auch
ungewöhnlich aber die situation ist
natürlich auch eine sehr ungewöhnliche
wir haben auch fragen von unserem
publikum an sie captain nemo über
youtube wie sollen denn finnland und
schweden in die nato aufgenommen werden
wenn die türkei schon ihr veto eingelegt
hat
also mir ist nicht bekannt dass die
türkei tatsächlich schon ein veto
eingelegt hätte im april noch oder ende
april hat noch präsident nächste von
finnland mit erdogan gesprochen und hat
nach dem gespräch berichtet dass es
tatsächlich ein positives gespräch
gewesen ist und deswegen würde ich da
jetzt eigentlich keine sorgen machen ja
also ich kann das auch nicht bestätigen
dass es da schon ein solches veto gibt
frage von mir rechnen sie mit einer
ähnlichen entwicklung im fall schwedens
die sind ja ein bisschen langsamer was
den ganzen prozess angeht da wird unter
anderem noch eine sicherheitsanalyse
erwartet aber auch da könnte es ja
relativ schnell gehen genau die
sicherheitsanalyse müsste morgen
auskommen und
tatsächlich gehen jetzt sozusagen so ein
bisschen den finnischen und schweden
gerüchte um das schwimmen den antrag
dann doch noch schon am montag nach
brüssel schicken könnte und jetzt machen
sich dann die finden wieder sorgen ob
wir dann doch noch diesen an zweiter
stelle sozusagen sein werden also mal
sehen ob da sogar ein kleiner wettlauf
entstehen wird ein wettrennen zwischen
finnland und schweden wir sprechen
gleich weiter frau allein da vorher aber
zeigt uns mein kollege pablo silaghi
warum die situation für finnland gerade
in bezug zu russland gerade eine
insbesondere ist sowohl geografisch als
auch historisch die gemeinsame grenze
zwischen finnland und russland ist rund
1300 kilometer lang eine längere hat in
europa nur die ukraine
zwischen finnland und russland verlief
der eiserne vorhang
im zweiten weltkrieg wurde finnland von
der sowjetunion überfallen die finnen
leisteten im sogenannten winterkrieg
erbitterten widerstand am ende waren sie
dennoch zu einem friedensvertrag mit
moskau gezwungen darin sicherte der
kreml zu den nachbarn nicht anzugreifen
so lange der sich aus der westlichen
verteidigung zusammenarbeit heraushält
während des kalten krieges blieb
finnland also gezwungenermaßen neutral
und ging auch nach dem fall des eisernen
vorhangs keine militärischen bündnisse
ein bis jetzt russlands angriffskrieg
auf die ukraine hat alles geändert
also eine jahrzehnte währende
neutralität und eine ganz besondere
rolle finnlands zunächst gegenüber der
sowjetunion und später dann auch
gegenüber russland wie würden sie
insgesamt das verhältnis ihres
heimatlandes zum östlichen nachbarn
bezeichnen beschreiben also es ist
natürlich schon immer ein recht
schwieriges verhältnis gewesen also da
wurde auch schon der winter krieg
erwähnt da hat sie auch finnland noch
das große glück dass finanz ich
verteidigen konnte gegen gegen die
einverleibung in die sowjetunion
sozusagen und hatte dann eben eine ein
anderes schicksal als beispielsweise die
baltischen nachbarn also das prägt sehr
bis heute die finnische
erinnerungskultur sozusagen der geist
des winter krieges und auf und damals
dieser satz nie wieder alleine also das
ist sehr bezeichnend für diese nato
debatte und warum bist dann jetzt so
schnell ging wo sozusagen die bedrohung
durch russland noch mal konkreter wurde
das bedeutet einfach dass finden hat nie
wieder alleine gegen russland dastehen
möchte obwohl wir natürlich sehr wohl in
der lage sind uns zu verteidigen
das ist auch noch eine interessante
frage darüber wenn man nachher auch noch
mit herrn müller sprechen über die
verteidigungsfähigkeit finnlands das ist
ja durchaus auch für die nato ein ganz
interessanter
aspekt wir haben ja noch einige fragen
über youtube wie lange würde es
offiziell dauern bis finnland in der
nato ist das haben wir gerade schon was
gesagt also nach unseren erkenntnissen
könnte das im besten falle noch in
diesem jahr passieren maximilian hübel
fragt wie sehen sie die
wahrscheinlichkeit einer weiteren
eskalation mit russland ja ich gebe dir
mal direkt weiter die frage weitere
eskalationen das wäre jetzt ja ein
schritt im moment der sowohl so oder so
interpretiert werden könnte wie sehen
sie also ich halte es für sehr
unwahrscheinlich also gewissermaßen sind
ja sowohl finden als auch schweden für
russland bereits sozusagen verloren
fälle weil beide schon seit 95 der eu
angehören also da gibt es kein zweifel
mehr an der west integration mit der
beiden länder deshalb ist auch jetzt der
nato-beitritt sozusagen sowieso nicht
mehr von russischer seite zu verhindern
und das wird auch anerkannt in russland
tatsächlich sind die reaktion eher
mäßig ausgefallen würde ich sagen heute
also bisher ist mir nicht bekannt dass
es irgendwelche vorfälle gegeben hätte
beispielsweise hybrider art oder cyber
attacken oder so was also damit hatte
man eigentlich gerechnet dass so etwas
passieren könnte sowohl gestern als
boris johnson helsinki besucht hat als
auch dann heute an diesem tag aber so
etwas ist bisher noch nicht bekannt
geworden und auch diese aussagen aus dem
kreml sind sehr in der bereits viele
jahre bestehenden tradition russlands
also das hat auch sozusagen nicht
überrascht und tatsächlich hätte man
sogar was stärkeres vielleicht erwarten
können dazu kommen wir gleich auch noch
mal an die oder beziehungsweise zu den
erwartungen die da jetzt oder
befürchtungen die da im raum stehen
könnten im moment auf finnischer seite
jens so fragt uns über youtube besteht
dieser vertrag dieser neutralität
vertrag aus der sowjetregierung immer
noch oder ist dieser inzwischen nichtig
und die ist natürlich also besteht nicht
mehr also mit mit der sowjetunion endete
auch dieser vertrag also das ist längst
geschichte also mit russland gibt es
einen ähnlichen vertrag nicht wenn ich
sie richtig verstehe genau
wir haben gehört jahrzehntelang war also
eine deutliche mehrheit gegen einen
nato-beitritt in finnland jetzt sind 75
prozent dafür 76 liest man auch
teilweise warum kann aus finnischer
sicht nur die nato die sicherheit des
landes gewährleisten nicht die eu zum
beispiel und das ist tatsächlich ein
teil dieser debatte gewesen also wie
stark ist diese beistands klausel der eu
artikel 72 42 77
und dadurch dass die eu eben nicht ein
eine verteidigungs union ist und die
eigenen kapazitäten noch recht gering
ausfallen ist man zu dem schluss
gekommen dass das dann halt eben nato
artikel 5 doch nur stärker ist und für
finden geht es eigentlich dabei
hauptsächlich um quasi so eine
zusatzversicherung könnte man so meinen
also die idee ist nicht die finnische
verteidigung an die nato sozusagen zu
outsourcen sondern einfach darum die
hürde irgendetwas militärisches oder
sonst gegen finnland zu unternehmen
möglichst hoch zu machen verstehe
es gab bereits wir haben darauf
hingewiesen eine offizielle reaktion aus
moskau die wir uns dann gleich nochmal
anschauen werden da werden wir auch noch
mit herrn berlin darüber sprechen aber
wie sehr fürchtet man in finnland die
konsequenzen die russland ziehen könnte
jetzt im anschluss an dieses vorhaben
sie hatten fünf schon andeutungen
gemacht
also die finnen haben nicht sehr viel
angst weil man kennt russland eben sehr
gut man hat auch schon viel vorgeschmack
von dingen die russland gegebenfalls
unternehmen könnte finnland ist auch
sehr gut vorbereitet auf alle
eventualitäten und zwar nicht erst seit
diesem frühling oder seit diesem
beitrittsprozess und deshalb unsere
kapazitäten uns auch dagegen zu
verteidigen und und darauf zu antworten
im passenden haus maß das ist alles auf
einer sehr guten basis und deswegen ich
glaube die angst ist tatsächlich anders
wo ein bisschen größer
ich glaube zum beispiel dass die hybride
einflussnahme russlands könnte
tatsächlich ein größeres problem werden
außerhalb finnlands die finden sind
resilient demgegenüber wir kennen das
einfach alles schon und haben eine recht
gute sozusagen medien lesefähigkeit in
der hinsicht aber zum beispiel in
anderen in der nato ländern befürchtet
man jetzt das russland gezielt dort
daneben sozusagen anti finnische
propaganda verbreiten könnte und
versuchen könnte da die stimmung daneben
gegen finnland zu kippen apropos
resilienz also widerstandskraft sie
haben es angesprochen finnlands
gegenüber russland was zum beispiel
diesen cyber sektor angeht aber wie ist
es zum beispiel mit der abhängigkeit von
rohstoffen das ist ja ein viel
diskutiertes thema gerade im westen
europas insbesondere in deutschland dass
man da sehr abhängig ist von öl von gas
aus russland wie ist die situation in
finnland also die situation ist deutlich
entspannter in finnland finden hat sich
nie in eine abhängigkeit begeben
beispielsweise also da sind die zahlen
manchmal ein bisschen verwirrend weil
man ließ öfters mal das finden bis zu
also knapp 100 prozent vom gas aus
russland
importiert und das ist zwar richtig nur
muss man das im kontext sehen weil in
finnland macht das nur fünf prozent
circa fünf prozent von dem gesamten
energiemix aus also deshalb ist das
nicht so schwer dann das zu ersetzen es
wird bereits daran gearbeitet schon seit
monaten jetzt und es könnte auch sein
dass russland den gashahn zudrehen wird
jetzt wohin lässt sich nicht auf diese
diese neuen systeme mit roo bezahlung
einlassen wird und bei ihm sieht es so
aus dass letztes jahr beispielsweise
waren ungefähr 85 prozent meiner ich vom
vom öl tatsächlich aus russland aber
auch da der gesamtanteil oder der anteil
im gesamtmix ist recht gering also bei
ungefähr 20 prozent und von den öl ist
auch das meiste bereits schon
wird schon anders von anderswoher
mittlerweile importiert das einzige
problem ist dabei eigentlich nur dass es
eben teurer ist also die russischen
alternatives im günstiger das heißt die
preise gehen schon sehr stark hoch nur
gibt es einen sehr starken konsens in
finnland das kein preis zu hoch ist
dafür zu bezahlen also der ukraine zu
unterstützen sich auch selber unabhängig
zum also eine richtige
prinzipienfrage dankeschön für ihre über
youtube juve 750 schreibt uns das ist
die richtige entscheidung und stärkt
unser nato-bündnis was passiert wenn man
als nachbar von russland nicht in der
nato ist sieht man ja aktuell in der
ukraine soweit diese einschätzung von da
ich danke ihnen ganz herzlich für das
gespräch vielen dank die zeit genommen
haben und einen schönen abend für sie
danke über den militärischen aspekt des
nato beitritts waren wir gleich mit
christian mölling sprechen wir hatten
das angedeutet vorher wollen wir noch
uns die erste reaktion des kreml
sprechers von dimitri peskow nochmal
genau anhören
eine abermalige ausweitung der nato
macht unseren kontinent nicht stabiler
und sicherer russland wird gezwungen
sein entsprechend zu antworten in
militärisch technischer und in anderer
hinsicht um den gefahren mit blick auf
seine nationale sicherheit rechnung zu
tragen
schönen guten abend herr delling ich
grüße sie
sie sind experte für sicherheitspolitik
mann haben wir gerade herpes kopf gehört
mit seiner einlassung da stellt sich
natürlich die frage welche bedeutung hat
jetzt dieser schritt finnlands und wohl
bald auch schwedens für die sicherheit
der nato für unsere sicherheit im
allgemeinen wie wollen sie das
einschätzen
ja also man darf perplexe weise sagen
dass sich natürlich die sicherheitslage
für moskau dadurch nicht verbessert und
man verliert jetzt quasi ein staat der
von neutral gewesen ist jetzt an die
nato das heißt er ist der ist gesichert
auf der nato seite das heißt auch dass
der militärisch strategische und auch
politische plan moskaus nicht aufgeht
die staaten zu destabilisieren die nicht
in der nato sind um sich drogen eine
einflusssphäre sicherzustellen ist genau
das gegenteil passiert in diesen
zusammenhang von daher verschlechtert
sich die lage für moskau aber wer ist
schuld daran moskau heute selber
verursacht hat so viel angst vor sich
geschürt dass es seine sicherheit auf
kosten anderer haben will das ziel das
schritt aus der finnischen sich wiederum
nur nachvollziehbar ist und was bedeutet
der schritt für die sicherheit der nato
und der nato-mitgliedsstaaten konnte
sich russland dadurch nochmal erneut
provoziert fühlen oder wie würden sie
das bewerten
also das muss man also sagen der an der
militärische
struktur und soldaten die auf dem grund
finnland stehen wird sich wahrscheinlich
gar nicht so wahnsinnig viel ändern
finnland war vor dem nato beitritt in
der lage oder zumindest darauf
eingestellt sich gegen russland
verteidigen zu können das heißt also da
gibt es keinen großen bedarf es ist kein
empfänger von sicherheitsleistungen
sondern finnland ist ein beiträge ein
netto beiträger sozusagen von
sicherheitsleistung zur nato man muss
auch wissen dass seit 2014 die nato
planung auch vorgesehen haben das ist
möglicherweise zu einem konflikt in
nordosteuropa kommt und für diesen
konflikt war es zwingend notwendig aus
nato sicht die planung mit finnland und
mit schweden gemeinsam machen zu können
das war völlig klar man muss praktisch
durch deren luftraum durch operieren
können auch wenn sie keine nato
mitglieder sind braucht man das
einverständnis und gleichzeitig war die
bedrohungssituation in den beiden
nordischen staaten so dass man
hat auch damals gab es für diese länder
schon eine zeitenwende von daher ist es
jetzt aus
natur sich eine verbesserung die damit
einhergeht und keine keine
verschlechterung ist kein zusätzlicher
aufwand der sich da jetzt mit soldaten
die verschlagen würde ja machen wir das
vielleicht gerade noch mal konkret sie
als sicherheitsexperte kennen sich
natürlich bestens aus also der beitritt
finnlands und schwedens wird ja von den
nato ländern insgesamt sehr positiv
begleitet was wäre denn konkret der
militärische gewinn so zu sagen
na ja also der militärische bin ich
glaube ich erstmal den politischen
willen in den vordergrund stellen wir
haben ein sicheres europa wir haben
keinen keinen vorteil dadurch wenn
finnland schweden unsicher sind sondern
einen zusätzlichen schutz zu
gewährleisten
ist in unserem interesse es ist ja auch
ein politisches symbolisches interesse
dass wir hier haben nämlich die länder
die sich zu den freiheitlich
demokratischen werten europas bekennen
in denen auch schutz
zukommen zu lassen von daher ist es
glaube ich nicht eine frage ob man jetzt
sozusagen auf dem spitzen einem spitzen
bleistift ausrechnen kann wie viel man
an vorteil dadurch hat klar ist man
hätte finnland und schweden sowie so
einiges art und weise mit verteidigen
müssen das hat auch was mit der
verpflichtung im rahmen der europäischen
union zu tun von daher ist es glaube ich
etwas nur ganz klar sagen kann 'die
gewinn an sicherheit dazu weil der
geostrategisch eine homogene
operationsraum gewinn und klar machen
dass die nato weiterhin offen ist für
die freiheitlich demokratischen staaten
wollen ja sie haben es gerade auch
angesprochen habe es auch für einen
beitrag schon gesehen die finden aber
auch die schweden nehmen seit jahren
bereits an nato übungen teil warum es
ist dennoch trotzdem wichtig dass sie
dann auch formal mitglied der nato sind
also es ist insofern wichtig als dass in
der tat in den letzten jahren man findet
in schweden sehr nahe an die natur
herangeführt hat beide länder dürften an
wichtig
auf der politischen und der
militärischen übernehmen aber
mitgliedschaft oder nichtmitgliedschaft
macht einen unterschied und musik machen
dh der das sozusagen das endgültige
versprechen des artikels 5 also die
gemeinsame verteidigungsbereitschaft
aller staaten gilt nur für diejenigen
die den vertrag mit unterschrieben haben
und deswegen so wobei tragen als auch
möglicherweise empfänger von von
sicherheit sind und jetzt kann man im
grunde genommen mit den wänden finden
und schweden beigetreten sind ihnen auch
sozusagen die letzten geheimnisse die in
der nato noch da sind wo man findet in
schweden nicht daran teilnehmen lassen
durfte diese kann man jetzt natürlich
teil jetzt ist ja ein neuralgischer
punkt wir bitten übrigens die
tonprobleme die es da manchmal gibt zu
entschuldigen kleiner versatz ist dabei
man kann sie aber trotzdem verstehen
jetzt gibt es einen neuralgischen punkt
sozusagen in der zeit zwischen
antragstellung und erlangung der
mitgliedschaft könnte putin in dieser
phase eventuell versucht sein
beispielsweise finnland anzugreifen weil
dann ja
noch kein bündnis fall eintreten würden
wie bewerten sie das
ja
kommt man sehr formalistisch
argumentieren dass wir da noch kein
bündnis weil wir haben ja eine
interessante situation also erstens nach
meinem verständnis gibt es direkte oder
indirekte sicherheitsgarantien für die
beiden staaten durch den durch die usa
diese hand vor allem die funktion einer
klagen signalwirkung richtung moskau
klar zu machen es lohnt sich nicht diese
staaten genießen auch wenn sie noch
nicht voll des nato-mitglieds sind
unseren schutz
das man sich vorstellen dass zwei
staaten die auf nato die den antrag
gestellt haben der nato beizutreten
die nato hat dem zugestimmt dass man
jetzt sagt bei jahre ein technisch also
bin ich mitglied das heißt wenn er jetzt
angegriffen werdet könnt euch nicht
verteidigen das würde ja quasi der
politischen philosophie der nato
komplett widersprechen nur bei man
sozusagen den ratifizierungsprozess
durchgeführt hat es ist auch
gleichzeitig komplett legitimen sollte
russland ein weiterer aggression wagen
nordosteuropa und findet angreifen dass
die nato staaten nach völkerrecht der
für finnland und auch schweden zu hilfe
eilen würden egal ob sie nato mitglied
sind oder nicht das heißt also es
spreche alles dafür und das ist klares
signal richtung moskau das es sich zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt schon nicht mehr
lohnen würde finnland militärisch
anzugreifen wenn es sich überhaupt
jemals gewinnt ich lese gerade nochmal 2
kommentare vor die uns über youtube
erreicht haben simon und kurz schreibt
das ist die nächste stufe der eskalation
es wird jetzt immer weitergehen bis es
doch knallt und dann fragen sich wieder
alle wie es so weit kommen konnte
dem kann man mit sicherheit auch
widersprechen lohne adoro schreibt uns
therapien nato zu spalten ging er wohl
komplett daneben dafür gibt es eine nato
erweiterung und zwei neue komplett
mitglieder mit finnland und schweden in
der tat dieser letzte punkt den würde
ich gerne auch nochmal aufgreifen wenn
man sich jetzt versucht auch wenn's
schwer fällt in putin hineinzuversetzen
das kann er ja nun nicht gewollt haben
also vor wenigen monaten hieß es noch
die nato sei hirntot zitat makro der
französische präsident und jetzt hat man
das gefühl sie ist vitaler denn eh und
je und in der tat mit demnächst neuen
mitgliedern ausgerüstet also hat er sich
da völlig verkalkuliert wie würden sie
das einschätzen
ja ich glaube das muss man tatsächlich
so zum jetzigen zeitpunkt konstatieren
dass er das nicht mit einkalkuliert hat
wieder das jetzt finnland und schweden
der nato beitreten
als auch das in deutschland zum beispiel
die zeitenwende kommt dass die
europäische union und die nato enger
zusammenrücken die letzten beiden punkte
sind interessant denn diesen effekt hat
dass 2014 schon gegeben und dieses mal
ist halt auch gerade dadurch dass ein so
sichtbaren invasions krieg gegeben hat
hat er wirklich alle roten linien
überschritten und das ist ein warnsignal
wir müssen uns vorstellen dass aus sicht
der finden und der anderen nordischen
staaten auch der baltischen staaten wenn
die auf das kriegsgeschehen der ukraine
gucken dann sehen sie sich als nachbarn
russland als die nächsten die dort die
brutale maschinerie moskaus tatsächlich
sehen könnten mit dem brutalsten
abschlachten von zivilisten und das kann
keiner wollen also von daher sehe ich
auch den aspekt der eskalation hier
drinnen nicht diese staaten haben ein
recht sich zu schützen sie möchten sich
schützen und wir haben sogar eine
pflicht sie gegen eine illegitime
illegale aggression zu verteidigen denn
nur so kann das recht auf dem wir alle
aufbauen tatsächlich geschützt werden
wenn ich ein recht habe dass ich nicht
durchsetze nämlich das recht auf freie
bündnis war das recht sich zu
verteidigen und das verbot von
aggressions kriegen dann kann ich diese
gesetze oder das völkerrecht im grunde
genommen auch gleich begraben
bleibt die alles entscheidende frage zum
schluss wie könnte der fahrplan für die
nächsten wochen aussehen an deren ende
dann womöglich endlich einen
waffenstillstand und verhandlungen
stehen haben sie dazu irgendeiner
effekt in die glaskugel ich weiß aber
haben sie dazu vielleicht eine
einschätzung wie das vonstatten gehen
könnte
ich glaube an dem fall braucht man gar
nicht in die glaskugel wir haben ein
nato gipfel der mitte juni stattfinden
wird ich gehe davon aus dass wir jetzt
schon die letzten wochen sehen dass es
ganz viele vorbereitungstreffen gibt es
gibt delegationen aus finnland und
schweden die hier in berlin gewesen sind
die in brüssel gewesen sind die auch in
ankara gewesen sind dh
da läuft gerade ein programm ab es wird
zurzeit in brüssel geprüft ob die
staaten formalen kriterien erfüllen
alles sozusagen auch bürokratisch sauber
und ich gehe davon aus dass man
spätestens zum nato-gipfel beide staaten
als neue mit mitglieds anwärter
zumindest begrüßen kann sie sind daher
auch formal mitglied aber ich glaube das
ist auch das was man sich an der iss
einmal an der dramaturgie vorstellt dass
man das bis dahin abgeschlossen hat und
ich glaube auch dass beide staaten hand
in hand einreichen werden und das ist
ein paar sachen prozess gibt diesen
beiden staaten reinzubringen es ist ja
tatsächlich etwas besonderes was hier
passiert beide staaten sind ja seit
langem teil der europäischen familie und
der europäischen union das stimmt also
das ist sozusagen ihre antwort bezogen
auf finnland und schweden ich zählte
jetzt eher auf die ukraine ab haben sie
da auch schon eine vorstellung wie da in
den nächsten wochen der prozess weiter
verlaufen könnte weil auch da wird es
irgendwann zu verhandlungen kommen
müssen
naja ob das wochen oder monate dauert
ich würde da gerne jetzt sozusagen der
der deutschen friedens sehen so keinen
vorschub leisten ich glaube wir müssen
uns darauf einstellen der amerikanische
verteidigungsminister das sehr klar
gesagt dies kann noch ein langer krieg
sein ich denke das kann über den sommer
bis in den herbst hinein gehen die
wesentlichen zwei faktoren die darüber
bestimmen wie lange dieser krieg dauert
ist auf der einen seite die versorgung
mit waffen munition
militärischen geht sozusagen auf der
einen seite und auf der anderen seite
die politische unterstützung die moscow
von seiner eigenen bevölkerung kriegt
und von den eliten die putin am leben
halten und die auf der anderen seite die
ukraine von ihrer bevölkerung aus dem
westen kriegt um diesen krieg der
ungleich ist tatsächlich weiterzuführen
jetzt habe ich gerade noch eine frage
reinbekommen hermeling und dann entlasse
ich sie über youtube nachwuchs
kämmerling hermeling denken sie es wird
konsequenzen für die nato haben also
dass man jetzt eben die beiden länder
aufnehmen gemeint sind offensichtlich
negative konsequenzen aber ich habe
darauf sind sie schon eingegangen das
befürchten sie jetzt erst mal nicht
also ich glaube schon dass bosque darauf
reagieren wird das muss man auch ernst
nehmen moskau hat aber heute auch sehr
klar gemacht durch durch seinen sprecher
dass es eine reziproke antwort geben
wird das heißt man punkte erst mal was
dann überhaupt genau passiert und darauf
wird es eine antwort geben das ist auch
in der sache logisch und richtig aus
moskauer sicht schlimmer wäre es wenn
man jetzt tatsächlich so wie das früher
früher am morgen heute ich sozusagen
vergeltung und wohnen würde dass moskau
aus seiner sicht sich absichern muss ist
klar ich glaube das woran wir allen
interesse haben ist dass wir relativ
schnell in einen stabilen strategischen
zustand zurück kommen in dem alle wissen
was sie zu erwarten haben und was
einseitig militärische aktionen bedeuten
würden ich glaube das ist dass es in dem
zusammenhang dass das wichtigste worauf
er zum jetzigen zeitpunkt achten müssen
christian mölling war das experte für
sicherheits und verteidigungspolitik von
der deutschen gesellschaft für
auswärtige politik vielen dank dass sie
sich die zeit genommen haben und für
ihre einschätzungen heute abend
dankeschön sehr gerne ja und auch euch
natürlich vielen dank fürs mitmachen für
eure fragen und kommentare bei mir an
dieser stelle euch einen schönen abend
zu wünschen und bis demnächst macht
dacia
[Musik]